et Elena volosin nous a rejoint pour vue
de Russie notre magazine hebdomadaire
qui analyse la propagande de Vladimir
Poutine sur fond de guerre en Ukraine
bonsoir Elena bonsoir hier Vladimir
Poutine a dialogué pendant plus de 4
heures avec les Russes avec des
journalistes également triés sur le
volet un échange retransmis en direct
par les télévisions russes et cela a
bien entendu fait la une de l'actualité
en Russie bien sûr les chaînes de
télévision Russie ont consacrit de longs
verbaam tout en encensçant Vladimir
Poutine pour sa prestation comme par
exemple le présentateur Vette Vladimir
soloviov dans son émission d'actualité
quotidienne c'était hier soir sur la
chaîne étatique
[Musique]
regardez je sais précisément ce qu'on
fait pendant 4 He aujourd'hui Biden schz
Macron rich sunac et pourquoi zelensk
était si
anxieux évidemment parce qu'il suiv en
intégralité la conférence de presse doué
de la LI président de la fédération de
russieladir
vladov il comptait combien il y avait de
questions se demandit si on allait
parler de si on laisserait parler leurs
représentants et on comprend
pourquoi et bien sûr comme souvent tous
ceux qui se considèrent comme de grands
spécialistes de la politique russe ass à
Londres Paris et dans les centres de
décision aux États-Unis ESS de lire
entre les lignes trouver ce qu'il y
aurait à redire mais il ne faut pas il
faut juste ce qui se
passe il faut voir comment le président
sans note ne redoutant aucune question
aucun journaliste aucun thème
embarrassant a répondu aux questions les
plus sensibles de façon calme concise
clairire et
réfléchie alors ce n'est pas tout à fait
vrai les questions on ét trié sur le
volet tout comme les journalistes des
pays dit inamic d'ailleurs par exemple
parmi tous les correspondants français
qui ont tenté de s'accréditer à cet
événement et bien seul une chaîne
française a pu l'être les internautes
ont toutefois remarqué quelques sms
embarrassant projetés sur les écrans
pendant l'émission hein derrière les
participants par exemple quand la Russie
réelle deviendra-t-elle identique à
celle qu'on nous montre à la télévision
comment peut-on déménager dans la Russie
qu'on nous montre sur la première chaîne
de télévision russe ne vous présentez
pas pour un nouveau mandat était-il
aussi écrit place aux jeunes ou encore
pourquoi le pouvoir local
fonctionne-t-il de telle manière que
l'on est forcé de s'adresser
personnellement au président a-t-on
besoin d'un tel pouvoir oui parce que ce
format médiatique est une sorte de
cahier de doléance où Vladimir Poutine
entend les Russes et résout leurs
problèmes en direct oui ce format il
existe depuis 2001 c'est-à-dire en fait
depuis que Vladimir Poutine est au
pouvoir et c'est un moment fondamental
en fait pour son culte de la
personnalité parce que pendant ces
heures d'antenne annuelles et bien
Poutine apparaît comme le faiseur de
solution et non le responsable des
problèmes du pays il agrège l'espoir et
non pas la rancœur des Russes au
détriment des échelons inférieurs du
pouvoir les gouverneurs les responsables
locaux qui eux du coup apparaissent
comme fautifs de tous les mots qui
secouent le pays et s'en presse
d'ailleurs d'aider les Russes dès que
ceci s'adresse à Poutine du coup chaque
année en fait des millions de Russes
s'adressent à Vladimir Poutine dans
l'espoir de mettre de l'ordre dans leurs
affaires et de lui demander de mettre de
l'ordre dans les affaires du pays
écoutez par exemple cette retraité la
manière don elle s'adresse à
Vladimir bonjour ch et respecté Vladimir
vladimirov mon cher président chez nous
la dizaine de coûte entre 180 et 220
roubles jamais vu de tel prix Vladimir
vladimirovz piti des
retrait nous ne touchons pas des million
avec notre retraite mettez de l'ordre
s'il vous plaît nousonsneautre N
c'est tellement dommage que vous ne
fassiez une telle émission qu'une seule
fois par an il faut le faire trois fois
par an pour que les gens puissent
s'adresser à vous je vous suis très
reconnaissante et je place mes espoirs
en vous pour que vous nous
aidiez donc on a vu cette dame qui
demande à Poutine de faire son émission
plus souvent parce qu'il est son dernier
espoir et c'est comme ça chaque année
oui cette émission entre autres elle
assure à Vladimir Poutine une code de
confiance qui plafonne au-dessus de 80 %
autour de 80 % quoi qu'il arrive même
lorsqu'il décide d'attaquer le pays
voisin et cette verticale du pouvoir et
la soumission en fait des fonctionnaires
à l'autorité du guide fonctionne
tellement bien que les quelques dizaines
de chanceux parmi les millions qui ont
la chance de passer à la télévision
russe et bien leurs problèmes se
résolvent souvent avant même que
Vladimir Poutine ne les entende pendant
cette émission regardez cette séquence
elle a été tournée par la télévision
russe dans le call center dans le centre
d'appel dédié à recevoir les doléances
des citoyens c'était quelques jours
avant le passage à l'entainne de
Vladimir
Poutine le nombre de question adressé à
l'émission bilan annuel de Vladimir
ptine dépasse ce soir le million et demi
dans moins de 2 jours le président
pourra répondre à une partie d'entre
elles pour la majorité un message au
chef de l'État représente l'unique
espoir et la seule possibilité de
résoudre d'importants problèmes ici
c'est la région de novgorode il y a 4
villages 7000 habitants et aucune
infrastructure pour les
enfants depuis de longues années nous
demandons aux autorités locales de nous
construire une école et un jardin
d'enfants accessible
mais ne nous entendent pas ils ont enfin
été entendus le gouverneur a pris le
contrôle de la situation nous
connaissons ce problème nous y
travaillons nous allons bientôt démarrer
les
plans 7 décembre soit 7 jours avant que
Vladimir avant Vladimir Poutine ce
gouverneur a tenu sa propre ligne
directe avec les citoyens sur l'antenne
régionale de la télévision publique
russe oui les gouverneurs et les chefs
de région ils prennent les devants parce
qu'ils savent que Vladimir Poutine est
aussi connu pour faire tomber des têtes
hier Poutine est apparu donc dans un
exercice de style bien rodé rassuré par
un public dit de journaliste mais aussi
en fait d'activiste comme toujours très
élogieux regardez
Flor nous soutenons tous votre décision
de vous porter candidat à l'élection
présidentielle l'an prochain parce que
moi depuis que je me souviens de
moi-même en fait bah vous avez toujours
été au
pouvoir je voudrais vous inviter à notre
stand à l'exposition
Russie voudrais vous remercier pour
l'idée de cette exposition quel succès
il y a eu un sondage ces jour-ci et 97 %
des Russes éprouvent de la fierté après
avoir visité cette
exposition en ses fêtes de fin d'année
chaque fillette même si elle est grande
rêve d'un Mirac c'est pourquoi j'espère
que vous accepterez de
venir merci beaucoup pour votre
invitation l'exposition en Russie qui se
tient en ce moment même à Moscou les
stands qui ventent le développement des
régions russes y compris celui des
nouvelle région comme on les appelle en
Russie c'est-à-dire des régions
d'Ukraine envahies et annexé par
Vladimir Poutine le président russe qui
s'est d'ailleurs vanté des succès
économiques et des succès au front
pendant son émission oui parce que la
nouveauté cette année c'est que ce
format se tenaé sur fond de guerre en
Ukraine l'an dernier d'ailleurs pour la
première fois hormis la période du covid
et bien il avait annulé ses rendez-vous
médiatiques annuels qui se tiennent
comme on le disait depuis 2001 sur fond
de difficultés sur le front et après la
vague de mobilisation en Russie qui
avait été pour lui on s'en souvient un
moment très sensible cette année
l'actualité est plus propice à Vladimir
Poutin il a été interrogé d'ailleurs sur
l'éventualité d'une deè vague de
mobilisation il a dit que ce n'était pas
à l'ordre du jour alors en tout cas les
femmes de mobiliser russes qui
protestent en ce moment à travers la
Russie elles n'ont pas eu la parole hier
ceux qui ont beaucoup parlé de la dite
opération militaire spéciale la guerre
en Ukraine donc au nom des combattants
russes sont les correspondants de guerre
des chaînes de télévision russes et
regardez comment ça se passe lorsque
qu'ils essaient de poser quand même des
questions qui dérangent un
peu estimez-vous que le système
déversement militaire marche
suffisamment bien aujourd'hui je connais
des gens qui attendent leur argent
depuis des
mois mais vous ne pouvez pas ne pas voir
que la situation s'améliore n'est-ce pas
non
mais elle s'améliore oui mais
aujourd'hui c'est un fait qu'elle
s'améliore mais bien sûr vous avez
raison on n'arrive pas toujours à tout
faire alors ensuite Vladimir Poutine lui
a répondu que ce problème tout comme
l'autre problème que soulève ce
journaliste c'est-à-dire le manque de
drone et bien ces problèmes il doit être
locaux il faudra s'y pencher mais dans
l'ensemble il n'y avait pas vraiment de
quoi le mettre en difficulté Vladimir
Poutine les règles du Poutin show si on
peut dire ont été respectés par tout le
monde et en premier lieu par les
présentateurs de l'émission ycatérina
et PAV ZAR charg aussi de trier les
questions en amont
regardez nous avons reçu énormément de
messages pour vous de la part de
citoyens de pays
européens
ouinormément des citoyens des États-Unis
qui voudra obtenir la nationalité russe
Italie
Suède plein de pays différents Allemagne
et vous savez ces histoires que ces gens
nous racontent sont complètement folles
par ex
une famille a été délogée de son
domicile lorsque l'opération militaire
spéciale a commencé les gens veulent
vraiment revenir en Russie et y vivre
alors on ne sait pas vraiment de quelle
histoire il s'agit dans ce cas précis ça
n'a pas été précisé on ne sait
d'ailleurs même pas si cette histoire
existe vraiment parce que la propagande
russe elle prétend très souvent que des
personnes persécutées dans un Occident
qualifié de russophobe par Vladimir
Poutine et bien voudrait obtenir l'asile
politique en Russie quoi qu'il en soit
une fois de plus le but de ce format
n'était pas de montrer une Russie qui a
des problèmes mais de montrer une Russie
dont le président détient les solutions
Vladimir Poutine il a aussi réitéré les
buts de son opération militaire spéciale
des naasification et démilitarisation de
l'Ukraine c'était l'une des premières
questions qui lui a été posée signe que
les Russes finalement ne comprennent
peut-être toujours pas très bien
pourquoi leur pays est entré en guerre
mais finalement ce n'est pas très grave
ils soutiennent quand même massivement
Vladimir Poutine y compris grâce à ce
genre d'émission merci Lena voilà ce que
vous pouviez dire sur ce fameux Poutine
show terminé pour vue de Russie merci
beaucoup on va passer à l'économie
économie avec Johanna citruc bonsoir
Johanna bonsoir Stéphanie vous allez
nous parler des pattes et en particulier
les pattes italiennes une industrie en
crise aujourd'hui oui ces derniers mois
plusieurs facteurs sont venus perturb la
production de patte en Italie a commencé
par la guerre en Ukraine qui a entraîné
de l'inflation et une crise du secteur
de l'énergie il y a aussi les effets du
changement climatique notamment les
fortes pluies ou les périodes de
sécheresse qui sont venus abîmer
détruire les récoltes de blé
autant d'éléments qui inquièteent les
Italiens il faut dire que le pays est à
la fois le plus gros consommateur et le
plus gros producteur de pates au monde
regardez ce reportage de notre
correspondante sur place Natalia
Mendoza cela fait plus de 50 ans que la
famille d'enri ovenenti cultive du blé
en émilieromagne une des principales
régions agricoles de l'Italie ces deux
dernières années les coûts de production
de son activité ont
explosé la guerre en Ukraine ont subi
une augmentation des prix en particulier
des engrais qui arrivent souvent de la
Russie ils ont triplé de prix mais aussi
le gasoil qui a
doublé comme les quelques 10000
producteurs de blé de la région Enrico
est inquiet à l'inflation galoppante
s'ajoutent les alléas climatiques au
printemps dernier la région a été
frappée par des pluies torrentielles ce
matin il cherche conseil auprès du
principal syndicat agricole du pays
après les inondations de mai dernier
comment ça s'est passé pour ton
activité avec les pluies continues on a
perdu la moitié de la récolte de cette
année c'est une année terrible pour le
secteur dublé en 25 ans de métier je
n'ai jamais vécu une année comme c-ci
Jama on estime que 20 à 30 % des
entreprises du secteur pourra arrêter de
cultiver du blé dur l'année prochaine
car avec cette crise de nombreux
agriculteurs vont préférer sorienter
vers d'autres
cultures une crise qui frappe également
les activités qui transformment le blé
comme cette entreprise qui produit des
pâes
farci regardez ici on a un tortellino
farci au prochout et au parmesan cette
farce nous coûte 15 % de plus par
rapport à l'année dernière le coup de la
p augmenté aussi nos coup de production
subissent des ha de prix de ma prè
transport
etnergie la conséquence est désormais
visible à la caisse en 2 ans le prix
moyen des pattes a augmenté de 32 % en
Italie dans deactualité économique le
géant du transport maritime mersque a
suspendu le déplacement de certains de
ces navires en mer Rouge oui ça concerne
l'intégralité des portesconeneurs qui
devaient passer par le détroit de Bab
almandab qui se trouve entre la pointe
sud-ouest du Yémen et Bouti son nom
n'est pas très connu mais c'est un point
de passage stratégique où transite
environ 40 % du commerce mondial le
problème c'est que depuis que la guerre
a éclaté au Proche Orient entre Israël
et le Hamas cette région est
régulièrement la cible d'attaque des
attaques menées par les rebelles outil
en provenance du Yémen et qui disent
vouloir se montrer solidaire avec les
Palestiniens mais au cours desquels
plusieurs navires ont été touchés d'où
cette décision aujourd'hui du géant
danois
mersque et c'est turky shline qui
annonce une éme énorme commande au
profit d'erbus la compagnie turque va
commander à l'avion Nord européen pas
moins de 355 appareils 230 de manière
ferme et 125 de façon optionnelle il
s'agirait à priori d'un mélange d'avion
moyen et long courrier le tout pour un
montant de plus de 40 milliards de
dollars selon les prix catalogues il
faut dire que turky shline a récemment
lancé un grand plan stratégique pour
élargir sa flotte à plus de 800 avions
d'ici 2033 elle en possède actuellement
merci Joanna c'est tout pour